hey guys Pete here Westworld season 1
episode 3 aired last night and a lot of
interesting stuff happened this will be
my recap and review for episode 3 and
will contain spoilers for everything
that's happened in the show up to this
point I usually do a scene-by-scene
breakdown in the first half with the
summary and thoughts on the story at the
end this time the video was getting
really long so I'm breaking it up into
two parts this part you're watching now
will be the scene-by-scene breakdown and
I will release the summary in a separate
video
tomorrow I've already recorded the audio
for both parts so it'll definitely be
coming out and you should check back for
that with all of that out of the way
let's get right APUs ode 3 which is
titled the stray starts off in the
programming Center we see that Delores
is there with Bernard and we noticed
that he asks her the same question about
talking to anyone else about their
interactions as he did the last time
this time Bernard brings Flores a gift
it's a copy of Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland and he tells her that he used
to read it to his son at night he has
her read a passage and asked her about
it she says it's about change and that
it reminds her of the other books
they've read there's no indication of
when they read other books which made me
question the timeline but in a later
scene when they meet again everything
appears to be in present time there is
an interesting exchange during their
talk where Dolores asked him about where
his son is he tells her that he's
somewhere she wouldn't understand and
then checks that her Diagnostics to find
out why she asked she responds by saying
that they have been talking for quite a
while and that she hadn't asked him any
personal questions personal questions
are an ingratiating scheme this is
interesting for two reasons one is that
Bernard wasn't sure if she was
improvising or not and the second is
that it gives us insight into how the
how the hosts operate it sounded natural
to us as viewers but it was actually the
product of her programming
I feel like Bernard was hoping that it
was a real question based on you know
their interactions but in the end it was
not at this point Laura still seems to
be without empathy or sympathy which
wouldn't be part of her core functioning
cut back to her in her loop waking up at
home we see her new father to remind us
what happened to the last one and then
we see her find a gun which appears to
be out of place in her routine she finds
it in her
top-drawer as she's putting something
away which is something she would do
every day but seems thrown off by it
being there of course we saw her find it
in the backyard while she was asleep in
the previous episode after she puts it
back she immediately has a flashback to
the barn and her run-in with the man
imply we know that this is an actual
memory of something that we saw happen
which is different from the other hosts
returning to their previous narratives I
think this will turn out to be important
but for now when she looks in the drawer
again the gun has disappeared it looks
like she gets back on her loop at that
point we find the guest William back in
Sweetwater strolling down the street he
passes Clementine and then sees a man
bringing in an outlaw to collect the
bounty he's intrigued by the scene and
while he's looking at the one it posters
the man's escapes and shoots all the
hosts that are standing around him the
outlaw takes Clementine hostage to use
as a shield in order to get away as he
moves into the street William pulls his
gun and we find out that the guest can
actually get shot when Boris fires on
him first
in the end William gets a shot in to
take him out rescuing the girl in the
process he turns down her advances when
she offers to take him inside and show
her gratitude and we find out when Logan
comes over that guest can't be killed
but they can be shot it looks like it's
something similar to getting shot with a
rubber bullet but they don't elaborate
on how it works when Logan tries to take
him to the brothel William says that he
has something else in mind he looks at a
wanted poster and says he wants to go on
an adventure
Logan tries to talk him out of it but he
decides to go anyways we go back to the
programming center where Teresa is
waiting for Bernhard he mentions not
getting much sleep tonight before what
she doesn't care about because she says
Ford's taking over the narrative at the
eleventh hour has the board worried she
tells him the Ford has carved out a huge
part of the park for his new storyline
and that has thrown a bunch of existing
storylines into disarray he asked if
there's anything he can do and she
reminds him that he told her that the
update problem was under control so
she's wondering why his staff are still
pulling the host to analyze them we find
Elsie checking out the hosts tenderloin
who we saw Walter pouring milk over just
before he was decommissioned when
researching this character to figure out
who he was I learned that he's the same
guy who played
the Geico caveman which is pretty
awesome anyways we learned that LC is
onto something here as she shows Barnard
the footage of one Walter glitched out
she tells him that the host is talking
to someone we find out that this someone
is named Arnold and that Walter killed
six hosts but he also let three go when
she went back and pulled the narrative
logs she found out that the six he
killed had all killed him and passed
stories and it was like he was holding a
grudge before Bernard can say anything
about that she gets a notification about
a stray host he tells her to go find it
and that he'll dig a little deeper and
get tenderloin back up on the surface on
the way up in the elevator once with
Stubbs we get a better idea of what his
perspective on things is he says that he
sleeps to this gun because the only
thing that keeps the host from revolting
is a line of their code at first it
seems a little paranoid but when you
think about it this is probably a good
attitude to have we find Teddy with a
female guest confronting a formidable
character to collect the bounty gun
fight breaks out and the and the guest
shoots the outlaw host after he draws
his gun they handcuff their prize to a
post outside the mariposa and head
inside for it to have a drink
mave isn't happy about them leaving the
body on the porch so Teddy gives her
some coin for the trouble as he grabs if
she has a flashback to when she saw his
dead body after waking up from her
nightmare
she looks put off by it and we don't
really see what happens next because
Teddy sees Dolores through the window
which brings his loop back up we see
that it starts out the same way it
always does when she drops the can of
condensed milk and he's there to pick it
up when they get out to the past year
the dialog changes a little bit
this time she says that what if she
doesn't want to stay there and says that
she wonders if there isn't somewhere
else they could go since he's been all
around their world she asks if there
isn't a place where they could go rather
than where they're at as he's telling
her about a place down south where the
mountains meet the sea where he's heard
that a person can start over we find out
about his drive when she puts him on the
spot about leaving right away he says
that he has some reckoning to do before
he can deserve a woman
like her they get back to the Abernathy
home and we see the normal narrative of
the bandits attacking before we cut away
back at the programming center we get
this really cool sequence of an eyeball
being built then we see the Ford has
Teddy there asking him questions he
tells Florida's aspirations are to build
a life with Dolores only she is better
than what he deserved for tells him
frankly that his job isn't to protect
the Loras but to keep her there so that
guests can find her if they want to kill
the wayward gunslinger and have their
way with his girl yes if Teddy has ever
wanted to run away with her to which he
replies that he has some reckoning to do
first
Ford's mentions his mysterious backstory
and says that they actually never gave
him one they only gave him a formless
guilt that he can never atone for
he tells Teddy that's why he's there and
uploads a new narrative was a character
named why today he describes him as a
sergeant that went missing and came back
with some strange ideas he says he was
true evil and that he thought he could
hear the voice of God back on the
surface we see tenderloin and a new
guest approach and propositioned Dolores
with the roll in the hay if she's trying
to leave Teddy shows up to challenge the
new guest who tells tenderloin he was
looking for something easy they decided
that she isn't worth the lead and they
all take off Dolores and Teddy then
leave together but instead of doing
their normal trip to the pasture we we
see him trying to teach her how to shoot
after he shows her what to do we find
out she isn't able to pull the trigger
not that she is afraid or doesn't want
to pull the trigger or something like
that but that she's physically unable to
do it which makes us realize that she
isn't programmed to do that at that
point the sheriff rides up with a posse
that includes the new female guest named
Marty that we saw Teddy with earlier she
says they have a new bounty and that it
sounds like a big one the sheriff tells
him the man in question gunned down an
entire village men women and children he
says he thinks that is Wyatt who's the
man that Teddy's been looking for for
quite some time
Teddy promises to Laura said he'll come
back and then rides off at the posse
because arguably the first funny scene
in the series where we find a bunch of
hosts arguing over who will cut the
firewood so that they can cook their
rabbit it's funny because we find out
from Elsie that they've been stuck in
this loop for two days on account of the
fact
that the stray host is the only one out
of the group who was authorized to use
the acts stubs points out that weapons
privileges have to be doled out
selectively inside the strays tent we
find that out that he's been programmed
to carve wood sculpture else he explains
that backstories aren't just to amuse
the guests but that they actually anchor
the host and that wood carving is his
cornerstone as they talk else he notices
that the stray has been carving a
pattern into his pieces and then they go
off trying to track him down we find
Teddy the sheriff and Marty riding in
search of Wyatt Teddy explains more
about Wyatt story where we learned that
his followers wear mat wear masks made
out of bones we also learned that they
are completely devoted to Wyatt and will
do anything he tells them to do he tells
the sheriff that he doesn't know all
this stuff from tracking Wyatt but that
he was his sergeant and his friend he
tells them that why it's strange ideas
were that the land didn't belong to the
natives or the new settlers that it
belonged to something that hadn't come
yet
it belonged to him they come across
three men tied to a tree who all looked
to be dead as Marty is inspecting the
bodies we realized that one is still
alive when it coughs on in the same
moment we hear a mysterious noise in the
background and the host from the posse
start getting shot while they're pinned
down we get the idea that why it has a
pretty large group of followers which
makes some of the guests in the posse
want to break off Teddy the sheriff and
Marty all decide to stay and they head
off into the trees Stubbs and Elsie are
still looking for the stray host and he
points out that the design on the
carving looks like a constellation this
leads to a little more humor when she
asked if he's Galileo and he says maybe
it's in his backstory Bernhard
approaches forward at the programming
centre telling him he wants to talk
before they go forward reprimands attack
us covered up one of the hosts that he's
working on he tells the tech that the
hosts don't feel cold they don't feel
ashame and that they don't feel anything
that they don't tell them to and then he
takes a scalpel to cut the hosts face to
make the point Bernard and Ford go into
his office to talk in private where Ford
seems annoyed that they're still talking
about the problems that came up after
the update Bernhard explains that they
figured out that the hosts weren't only
accessing old storylines but
they were actually hearing voices
Arnold's voice we find out that Ford
didn't create the park alone that he
actually had a partner in the early days
named Arnold who was no longer with the
company who was happy to scrub his name
from the history of West world we get a
great flashback to when they were
developing the park which includes a
shot of a young dr. Ford he explains in
the beginning that they worked on the
host without any guests to worry about
he says that the host learned to beat
the Turing test in the first year but
that wasn't good enough for Arnold he
wanted to create consciousness Ford goes
into a somewhat technical explanation of
what Arnold was trying to do based on a
psychological theory called the
bicameral mind which boils down to the
human mind having two parts one that
appears to be thinking and a second that
listens in obeys Barnard points out that
the hypothesis of early humans
developing thinking that their thoughts
were the voice of gods had been
disproven and Ford specifies that Arnold
was not using it as an explanation of
consciousness developing but as a way to
build consciousness or bootstrap
consciousness Ford points out that
Arnold failed to take two important
points into consideration first in an
environment like this the last thing you
want them to be is conscious into the
other hosts that believe their thoughts
were actually the voices of gods this
led to lunacy and they abandon the plan
with only the commands they used to
control them left behind they go back
and forth a bit and then Bernard asked
what happened Arnold Ford says that he
died in the park and that his personal
life was somewhat tragic he explained
that he basically got lost in his work
in his search for consciousness and in
the end it and talked to anyone but the
host in his isolation he started to see
something in them that wasn't there for
dense ends Bernard away with a warning
not to make the same mistake as Arnold
don't see something in the host that
isn't there they aren't real and they
aren't capable of consciousness when
Bernard asked why he would for talks to
him much in the same way they talked to
the host he tells them that he knows
that the death of his son still bothers
him almost making it sound like it's his
drive or his cornerstone we next see
Bernard in the Communication Center
talking to who we think is his wife or
maybe an ex-wife the scene could
disprove a popular fan theory that
Bernard is actually a host himself or
could
be part of the whole entire set up
haven't really bought into the theory
wholeheartedly but the last bit with
Ford makes it seem more plausible either
way he talks to his wife about their son
and he says that this pain is all that
he has left of them other than that we
come away with the idea that the park is
really inaccessible that while they're
working there the employees don't have
much contact with the outside world run
an interview with the showrunners and
they were talking about that which it
made sense because they were saying that
what's the kind of intellectual property
they have there they wouldn't want
people to be able to come in and take it
away catch back up with Stubbs and Elsie
who while slipping away for a second
finds the stray she finds him stuck in a
crevice where he's unable to escape we
cut away to the tree over tracking down
Wyatt they have a run-in with his
followers and there are a couple key
things that stand out in this scene
beyond just teddy into the sheriff being
massacred the first is their look they
do have mass that looked like they're
made out of cattle skulls and maybe some
of them are made out of other kinds of
skulls the second thing is is that they
aren't carrying guns but instead all
seem to be wielding axes and knives
this parts interesting since we know
that the stray who was likely headed in
their direction was programmed in such a
way to use weapons like that
the third notable thing is the most
confusing we see Teddy give Marty
something and then he tells her to leave
as she goes he makes the last stand
where he shoots a bunch of them at close
range but it doesn't seem to do any harm
to them at all like it doesn't seem to
slow them down and even a little bit as
they close in to hack him to bits
I've watched it several times and I
didn't notice either Teddy or Marty
killing or wounding any of them with
their rifles either I also can't tell
what he gave her before she left if any
of you guys know what it is like what he
passed her definitely let me know in the
comments I mean you can see it's gold it
looks like a tube but I don't know what
else it is beyond that back at the stray
Elsie tries to call Bernard who doesn't
answer while Stubb suits up to enter the
crevice she tells Bernard on the phone
in a message that the stray got an idea
in his head one that hadn't been
programmed we go back and we find out
that Bernard doesn't answer because he's
with Dolores his top with Ford has
apparently got to him and he tells her
he needs her help that he was just
fascinated and
he thinks he might have made a mistake
he tells her that this place that she
lives in is a terrible place for her and
she instinctively goes into her speech
about some people choosing to see the
ugliness before he cuts her off he tells
her to lose all scripted responses and
to go into improvisation mode only he
asked her to imagine that there are two
versions of herself one that feels these
things and asked these questions and one
that is safe which would she rather be
she says she doesn't understand that
there aren't two versions of her there's
only one she thinks that when she
discovers who she is that she'll be free
and this is the part that seals the deal
for Bernard he asks analysis what
prompted that response and it replies I
don't know Dolores asked if she's done
something wrong or made a mistake he
responds by telling her the same thing
for told him before that evolution has
formed the entirety of sentient life on
this planet using only one tool the
mistake he says it appears she's in good
company and then asked her if he ever
told her the story about when he was
teaching his son how to swim about how
Charlie was afraid to let go and how he
was and how he also was afraid to let go
he said he had to that's what parents do
and then he tells the Laura said he
isn't gonna change her back when she
asks he said let's go down this path and
see where it takes us when she gets back
to town she sees the sheriff's deputy
who brought the scared guests back to
town ride up she overhears him telling
another man that Wyatt's men laid a trap
for them she asks if he's going to go
back up there which he says he will once
the Rangers get there but he leaves her
with an ominous saying of if there's a
merciful God those men are hopefully
already dead we see her pick up with her
narrative arriving home just in time to
hear the gunshots on top of the hill
when she arrives at her father's side
tenderloin grabs her while he has a hold
of her she sees a memory of her old
father lying on the ground in the place
of the new one he drags her into the
barn and throws her onto the pile of hay
we see that this time she grabbed the
gun out of his holster along the way
though he gives the speech of a man
who's met his match but that but she
still isn't able to pull the trigger one
she first tries as he starts to advance
on her she starts to see the man in
black she then hears a voice in her head
kill him and is able to override her
programming to pull the trigger and
shoot him in the neck I noticed it
doesn't sound like Bernards voice which
we've seen her here in the past it
almost sounds like Ford but I guess it
could be Arnold or even someone else
who's insignificant here can't really
tell and when she shot the the figure of
the man in black you know we actually
see tenderloin died not the man in black
he takes off from the barn while he's
dying and there's another sequence I
don't quite understand she's moving away
a guest says hey come back here the
first time we see this happen he shoots
her in the stomach and we see her start
to bleed right now she's looking at the
wound she hears him say the same thing
over from the beginning only this time
she's able to get on her horse and ride
away like I said I don't really know
what this is supposed to represent like
did she anticipate what was going to
happen so that she could avoid it or was
we go back to Stubb's who now has
lowered himself down to where the stray
is and Elsie has put him in sleep mode
he opens up a kit to take out a saw
saying that they only need to get his
head back to the center he tells her to
look away as he starts the work at
cutting through the neck once he gets
part part of the way through the host
wakes up and starts this make his way up
the Rope towards Elsie after knocking
Stubbs on the ground she tries to stop
it by turning it off then decides to run
away only to fall on the ground as the
stray is coming out of the crevice he
picks up a rock which we think he's
gonna kill her with but then starts to
bash himself in the head until he falls
over this is a pretty key development
which I'll talk about in the summary
later William and Logan are at a
campfire where Logan is complaining
about spending 40k a day to sit in the
woods alone playing white hat the
hearing noise which we found out find
out is Dolores tumbling through the
woods she collapsed in his arms and the
episode end that's it for the
scene-by-scene so I'm gonna end this
video here make sure you check back
tomorrow to watch the second half with
the summary of the major points of the
story and a look at some of the
different questions that it brought up I
also talked about a few of the most
popular fan theories that are out there
right now and what this episode means
for them please like the video if you
enjoyed it and subscribe so you won't
miss the second part thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon